well good morning john i am still
recovering in various ways from the
project for awesome the last of my
physical consequences is that i put a
lot of socks on my hand at one point
wasn't a big part of the project for
awesome there were so many socks and
they pushed on my hand so much that i
got an ingrown hair on my hand and it
hurts i am however still working through
my my emotional and psychological
consequences one way to do that is with
a project for awesome meme review last
year i was able to go through pretty
much everything that was uh uh sort of
created as a part of the project for
awesome this year there were over 600
pieces of art and memes i have narrowed
that down to 250 of them and there are
last year there were three categories
this year there are six we've got crank
green we've got john purple we've got
two the moon we've got other we've got
art and there was one other thing otis
memes and since this is a meme review
we're gonna start off with the just
memes here's one we'll never get to
three million uh and the nerdfighteria
says i took that personally because john
was not ready to live up to all of his
promises and yet now he must working all
my night beans
henry green gets born domino's fall 2022
john gets whammed in the stomach i call
this icy milk i say in a room in my home
this is not my home it looks very nice
it looks very far off the ground but
they took the time to make sure i was
wearing weird socks which is accurate
possibly there's an octopus named hank
in in the nemo movies uh and in this one
i'm it's it's a green one and it's
looking at beanie sanford good old
beanie sanfurbs came back for for uh
some guest appearances but was not the
mascot of this year's project for
awesome we'll get to that we're gonna
need a bigger banana loca because me and
brennan lee milligan were trying to
figure out how we're gonna stuff
different things full of beans more
efficiently
this is john trying to
to figure out the wordle with me and
just not being able to hit vivid even
though we had the first four letters
kitty time is a finger in the project
for awesome and there was an armadillo
which is not a kitty but the chat was
confused darcy is a dog who started a
good portion of the project for awesome
got a little carrot every time they hit
five thousand dollars so that dog was
paying close attention to the stream
john persuaded the chat against tattoos
hank talking about crap i was very
excited about crabs this project for
awesome there's always beans in the
banana loca
there's always money in the benin stand
you got both there's both of those
things
happening if i had a nickel for every
time hank green said corn dog asked me
i'd have two nickels which isn't a lot
but it's weird that happened twice right
is it time for me to explain crank green
nah let's do it later just look at it
and be confused be a good crab the
balloon said look at me i look wonderful
i look like a crab jeez there's a lot of
crab memes in here i guess i do have to
explain it i i popped a balloon and it
told me to be a crab and it said it said
be a crab you have to be good at it part
of the challenge was being good at it so
i had to ask everybody very earnestly if
i was a good crab and they seemed to
agree that i was i'm once again asking
for give me the crunch now donating to
support charities nah donating so darcy
gets a carrot
i forgot about this moment until i saw
this meme but yeah i did shout that once
when someone was drawing a cursed furby
i was like
it's not not cursed enough yet i have to
do a good crab i did shout oh my knees i
did it a long time my knees hurt at one
point during the project for awesome i
stuffed a corn dog full of beans
and this meme was made which has made me
laugh
more than anything else it's a normal
corn dog
it was not normal there were beans in it
this was also made as a follow-up just
to like add
layers a normal corn dog it's a corn dog
it was not a corn dog
liking to eat their cursed foods tahan
yeah so taha built a terrible sandwich
and it turned out he kind of liked it i
did the same thing i stuffed baked beans
into a banana and like it turned out it
was pretty good this is a great meme
that is specific to the person who
created it it's time you learn about
money and the importance of
please make sound financial decisions we
don't vibe check on p foreign think i
said this in like the first hour and i
was like this is the this is correct at
one point i said that i really wanted my
forehead to be on wikipedia and somebody
made it happen though only temporarily i
didn't mean for it to be the one that i
had written butt on the balloon made me
do it uh is this a meme or is it just a
thing that i kept saying because i
popped balloons and they had tasks
inside of the balloons for me so the
balloon made me do a lot of things for
clarity the banana loca is a device that
is supposed to put filling inside of
bananas and i used it to put feelings
that shouldn't be in bananas and bananas
and also baked beans inside of a corn
dog
because i because i wanted to and it
turned out it was delicious so i was
right
have you heard the good news very early
in the project for awesome i got a
little bit obsessed with whether or not
foreheads are part of the face it turns
out according to all definitions it
totally is so i gave up on that one
crank is what they call the crab version
doing what the balloon says knees
holding me back they hurt right now
they're not from being crank just from
being hank make a normal project for
awesome cake or make a terrible crab the
terrible crab is what got made thank you
chapa for the beautiful terrible crap
we'll get to that body frost and baked
beans really do go very well together um
just like baked beans and bananas i
didn't even notice there's a tiny little
beanie sand verbs down in there this is
just a dinosaur with a space helmet on
yelling about how you are awesome and
worthy of care and respect this was my
desk after the project for awesome and
somebody noticed the baked beans with
the spoon still in and also confetti
that had fallen into it right next to
the fugu poison blowfish flavored potato
chips from rhett and link and the
mythical team i have cleaned up since i
actually cleaned up kind of rapidly
because i knew that if i didn't do it
soon i wouldn't do it at all there is
lots of confetti around there's actually
some stuck to the light that's above me
it is as john said everywhere like i
will be finding it for years this is the
story of the hour moving away from
beanie sanferbs and toward crank green
who at least in my portions of the
stream was definitely played a starring
role and i i we saw less and less of
beanie as the show went on john's big
moment on the other hand was this where
he went for some purple hair dye this
was chosen by his children and then some
some mustache uh pink dye it comes from
a spray paint can so just like
it's it's a beautiful thing it's true
there's only one way that you can kind
of get away with writing blood on your
head as a 41 year old so i'm glad that i
found the way this is certainly the case
for me uh the product for awesome is the
flex tape that we all need right now to
stop the giant hole
in our acrylic water tank
deltify which is the website that we use
for our like donations crashed
immediately when the project for awesome
went live so uh this was created by
people who during those 15 minutes when
we couldn't get in were like i wanted
apparently the chat didn't love my
commentary when i was shoving beans into
the corn dog hole another one yeah i
wasn't looking at all i was i was in my
own zone it was a lot of work to try and
make the banana loco work correctly so
you know i was just i just was saying
what was happening there was a magical
piece of confetti at the beginning of
the stream maybe spiderweb maybe sad
electricity maybe dave the fish watching
over us maybe just a project for awesome
america this meme always of course hits
you right in the feels uh but wow they
found it was that a good crab no i'm
told you were the best hank using live
stream time charity videos or beanie
sand verbs can't you just like do this
both at the same time this is the face
he was so panicked about it okay i like
a picasso do you want a marie condo and
ask if it sparks joy or do you just want
to go through your house and see what
you could sell for charity because
that's what john was doing and it worked
when donations are sky high like a
flying pizza pie it's a torrey at torres
our friend from save the children who
visits us every project for awesome
stream to talk about the work that they
are doing and that is the last of our
memes actually there was one more
[Laughter]
john did a blindfolded taste test and uh
he was tired he was tired of sardines
obviously i mixed the dinosaur ones in
there i didn't do a great job of
categorizing it it seems like but here's
some more dinosaur to the moon destin
time project for awesome memes you are a
t-rex at the jameson space telescope and
no one can take that away from you we've
also got i want to send you to the james
webb space telescope that dinosaur mask
and helmet
really did do it it was very iconic and
here's just a beautiful piece of art
he's very encouraging he's on a backdrop
of space i am going to send so many
dinosaurs to the moon god bless destin i
am once again asking you to send a
dinosaur to the james webb space
telescope this is what bernie sanders
actually wants for the world i receive
500 for charity you receive a completely
free dinosaur trip to mars it's a good
deal this was super cute there was a
proposal and so we have made some loving
dinosaurs i don't actually know what
this is about i don't know if i missed
this moment or if this person just made
a beautiful fairy dinosaur more dinosaur
on the moon and then this one is amazing
because it's all illustrated except for
in the dinosaur's mouth you can actually
see destiny we're gone to the moon this
is a lot in one category and this
category is called crank green starting
off with this from rachel it's just uh i
want to be a crab so now we've got album
cover art for the hit single i want to
be a crap this is the thing if you told
me i was a bad enough crab i would have
done it again and so everybody had to
struggle with that decision but you were
all very kind amazing pelican art i'm
having the boba fish and i got a crank
green on my pelican nose i'm wearing a
beanie sanford shirt everything's
perfect about this i want this jacket
it's so cool now beanie sanford is
watching me on a stage trying to be a
crab and i get that and i get that i've
got the word butt written on my forehead
and i get that i'm saying am i doing a
good job but why is there weird blue
lightning coming out of my eyes it
levels it up for sure but why frank's
daily diet in its natural habitat i got
that purely fun sweetened diced tea
which i forgot that i did talk about in
the beginning got chicken in my mouth we
were talking about how chicken crabs
like chicken and then i got a corn dog
um i like this uh just because of how
chaotic it is you just slap my eyes with
glasses on any crab and it looks like
there's crank green oh this big old face
i think that this person was uh making
this like sort of repeatable nft style
art with beans wearing coats and this
one is the crab the crab bean wearing a
trench coat 473 beans in a trench coat
was a an early joke that i can't even
really remember the origin of i've lost
it this is a cute little one somebody
thought half day did this one uh
obviously and oh it moves it moves it's
legit this is amazing at the energy of
it this was a photoshop job that i then
used to create a filter so that i could
actually hang out with people as crank
green on the stream so
anything is possible and then art was
made based on that so this is like a
painting version of that photoshop you
got a furby crab why not be a crab you
have to do a good job adorable it'll
crank green there just like that's
exactly what i look like then then this
look at his face and then cute ones i
mean there's like the hor the kind of
horrifying ones with the human mouths
and then there's the cute ones and the
more cute ones even this one's got a
plaid shirt on like i usually do and
also you can see this one's got really
rock hard abs and then our final piece
of crank green art here here it is i get
eyes normalized and i also get crab eyes
thank you to elisa for that i should
mention that if you want to see the
creators of all of these you got the
digital download bundle all of these
will be uh labeled with the
people who actually made this art which
we were able to do this year because we
had them submit it most of these some of
these i found
on twitter and
i they were not in the digital uh
nerdfighter art pack but some of them
are and that brings us to now that we've
done crank green we of course have to do
john purple so obviously john with
purple hair and a pink mustache
surprisingly kind of elegant once he got
through the crisis though in this
picture he's definitely still in the
crisis moment i know john it's not toxic
they wouldn't i mean maybe a little bit
look at that boy i love that one then he
starts getting cool look at this boy
maybe he should have a pink mustache and
purple hair all the time got very good
pizza john style here i would love to
see it spray painted on a wall somewhere
legally i got purple hair and a pink
mustache and i've got a serious message
to deliver this is a really cute one you
got a vibe and you got a threat i think
that jon made some kind of joke that was
this but i wasn't there to hear it but
regardless the art is beautiful this is
princess pizza john from alice the skirt
goes very high up but
i
do love it like the color scheme is
great the pink mustache and the purple
hair is actually really good that one's
great like very very 70s freddy mercury
this is a really cute look at him this
is my favorite brother i love the idea
of this being a batman joker like being
a bad guy and like but he looks like
that like what is that guy like he's not
like john green he's getting business
done and and if you give him a quarterly
report that he's not happy with you're
out look at that man i'm terrified good
pizza john oh no here oh that was very
small but you see it it's a princess
pizza john that's so cute i love it a
thousand stars how do you quantify
this thank you hannah for this
thing same quote again except i'm there
now and it says butt on my forehead and
john is looking very serious but now
he's got his great it's great hair and
mustache and then this
with
you know crank green and
john purple together happy 15 years
indeed what a marvelous time it has been
there's a lot of other there's a good
amount of 473 beans in a trench coat
there's a good amount of bean crab man
more beans in a trench coat crabs love
chicken so if if crab was pizza john it
would say chicken we've got a pelican
with my glasses on got lots of crabs
just drew a lot of crabs you got me hans
hoffman science goth mothman can i
explain it not really decrease world
suck you have to do a good job kimmy
made a bizarre beast's pin of crank
green the bean crab not bean crab just a
regular crab but he is surrounded by
beans of course we talked a little bit
about people getting confused uh and
thinking that an armadillo was a cat
this is just a lovely armadillo cat me
as dr horrible getting ready to see some
really dastardly experiments this is my
science boy-less show mercury stardust
proposed this idea which i think is a
great idea
that i'm not going to do here's john a
hug and chewbacca i missed this part of
the stream there was quite a bit of john
and chewbacca stuff it's beautiful they
are very happy together when brennan and
i were doing banana loca stuff we found
the banana logo website we found out
that there was a banana loca community
here's never sneezer scrooge confronting
the spirits of sneezes past present and
future are saying sneezing is not normal
i love that he's got pizza john's face
more beans in a trench coat from luisa
from luna we're here because we're here
pizza john this probably just should
have been in the art folder this is from
mickey me with butt on my head and a lot
of lipstick on i mean i believed
johansen to my very core that he was
giving me good advice on how to put on
lipstick while i was blindfolded he was
like my wife says you should always push
really hard like
why did i think that was the real thing
a person would say it turned out well
for entertainment value but i cannot
believe i just believed it this
i love his face he looks very hardcore
but he's got confetti on his hat and
he's holding up his sign this is kippers
he's wearing a purple mask here we are
the the green brothers and we're
adorable legitimately what a good couple
of brothers i'm very happy to be
to have this relationship in my life
here's the project for awesome miracle
uh confetti that was hanging in mid-air
uh some kind of glitch in the simulation
definitely not a spider web some more
beans in a trench go and here is world
suck over time and it goes down and it
goes up and it goes down but over the
long haul
we head to a better world thank you to
at waffley original and that is the last
of the others which means that what we
have left all that we have left is the
art starting off with this we're here
because we're here infinite oroboro's
thing also was from waffley original
look at that darcy
in a dinosaur costume very good very
cute chaos during dustin's segment uh
we've got
dustin's mike was not able to handle his
enthusiasm does not start at zero
obviously we just want to be clear about
the scale of the graph here started very
high continued to go very very high this
is beautiful when it was small just the
thumbnail i was like is that hope made
of beans i can only see beans great
sticker pack we've got the yeti we've
got the color of the inside of a
watermelon it's no we've got curiosity
rover we've got beanie santa verbs
asking for your financial support lots
of awesome socks hanging out around
there this uh is a can of heinz baked
bananas because i got very confused at
one point i thought that somebody was
saying that there were cans of bananas
and it was literally like there there
was no reality to this i was just
confused but it was good for the art
because i love this can of heinz baked
banana this is is from katherine liu
it's a watercolor page of a lot of the
things that went down during the project
for awesome so you got all the good
stuff here you got dinosaurs and love on
the moon you got me being a crab you got
beans inside of a corn dog you got john
purple you got beans and trench coat you
got darcy you got crank green thank you
for sharing your skill and talent some
more uh dinosaurs in love on the moon
this is the template for the beans and
trench coats um here's one of them this
is me crank and then there's there's
john purple should i make this my icon
on twitter i mean yeah i should this is
what it's like to be inside the project
for awesome here's more of crank green
science bullets show i do need to get a
crab shirt the light soaked days are
coming i thought this was really pretty
the hope is the thing with emily
dickinson's forks can i explain that to
you quickly no i kind of can't i just
have to i just have to move on here is
choppa's ridiculous crank green cake
this is an actual cake that you could
actually eat and it's me as a crab i
don't need to talk more about that you
understand how amazing that is john and
i have done very few like photo shoots
together we did one at vidcon where this
picture came from that that you may have
seen of us on a yellow background and to
adapt it to include john purple and
crank green
you are a good burrito self-care bunny
dftba baked beans with some confetti in
it don't forget to be ant don't forget
to be ant you got more going to the moon
you got handkerfish tie-dye art you got
darcy being an absolute monarch here you
got john green being some kind of
monarch as well i don't know where this
came from i don't know if this was
referencing anything in particular or if
they just did it this is a beautiful
piece of art of the cake itself this
said this is notable and i don't know if
this was something that was said on
stream or if it's just uh
a banana with this is notable underneath
it but i liked it a lot we're here
because we're here art
taha's really bad sandwich i gotta say i
would hate this sandwich full screen
three million excitement with the
dinosaur and the crab and the john john
purple all together here's some art that
somebody did of i think themselves
enjoying the project for awesome over a
long uh a long weekend i didn't see this
one during the peafory at all so this
one came up afterwards and that this
pelican with crank green in its mouth
was just absolutely extraordinarily
charming to me so thank you so much for
making that 23 flavors of confetti dr
pepper dfdb and this sticker sheet
very good i don't get this one i don't
know what's going on um from sylvia here
i don't know if this is a reference to
something but
it's really special things that make me
laugh
in this image one the giraffe's horn is
hitting one of the lights because it's
so tall two the giraffe is lifting its
hand up so it can read its notes with
its little backwards knee three there's
another giraffe in the audience watching
which gives me the vibe of supportive
family member and or
significant. it's got my guitar and the
the open mic host is wearing a pizza
drawn shirt five the woman's face as she
looks to her friend like what is
happening right now
that woman is all of us and then maybe
six the face of the open mic host who's
like i don't know how to get the mic up
to your mouth
sylvia thank you so much and then we
have just because you pelican doesn't
mean you pellet should never follow that
advice during the project for us but i
never will and finally though i
absolutely do want to go on forever and
ever i'm going to end with a piece of
art that it was unexpected to me i did
not expect to get what this is which is
a poetry collection of things that we
said during the project for awesome get
your greasy corn dog hands off
dictionary.com
face industrial complex for the love of
god we lose no one at the dinah space
program oh no we did lose someone
destined to float forever feeling the
air leak out and the void rush in
this is what the balloon told me to do
is what i will say to my wife
later tonight that was because i just
written butt on my forehead you can read
that whole thing if you've got the
digital download bundle as well as some
several other non-meme creations and all
of the art and memes that i didn't have
time to show you on john and everyone
who participated in the project for
awesome no matter how you participated
thank you so much for all of your
enthusiasm your creations your donations
your videos your votes it was
really wonderful and exactly what i
needed at that moment thank you meme
reviews are exempt from the four-minute
time limit as established last year and
john i will see you on tuesday